[Musica]
Nicolò Scusa non gli avevamo detto che
non toccava lui adesso sì sì gliel'ho
detto ma a quanto pare non ci ha
ascoltato Ah ok Vediamo che fa
[Musica]
Ok l'Ambra Mi dai 5 minuti Grazie
il termine evoluzione è legato
etimologicamente alla parola sviluppo
che è il contrario di inviluppo quindi
evolvere o evolversi è un po' come
districare
l'evoluzione Cioè non è un percorso
rettilineo ma è un susseguirsi di
numerosi tentativi con molti fallimenti
e pochi successi
che sono quelli che poi portano a un
risultato finale
Darwin aveva intuito bene questo
meccanismo che sta alla base degli
organismi viventi anche se lì per lì non
tutti gli diedero retta probabilmente
c'erano i negazionisti anche quella
volta
ma quasi a voler sottolineare il suo
stesso concetto
l'idea di Darwin è sopravvissuta e le
idee buone spesso sopravvivano
in natura è l'ambiente adoperare la
selezione a decretare il successo o
l'insuccesso di un determinato organismo
e per l'uomo Come funziona Beh noi nel
corso della nostra storia abbiamo
inventato delle tecniche delle strategie
abbiamo anche cercato di replicare noi
stessi
per esempio la progettazione
è una tecnica Dove è il progettista
a prendere le decisioni a forzare
L'evoluzione del sistema
sarà poi il mercato a decidere se è un
progetto un'idea ha successo oppure
oppure no
i robot nasce dal desiderio dell'uomo di
replicare se stesso
e la robotica umanoide
probabilmente non è la più utile
ve ne sono di più utili pensiamo alla
robotica industriale o alla robotica di
servizio con i robot che ci puliscono la
casa ma la robotica umanoide è
sicuramente esercita su di noi un grande
fascino peraltro ultimamente
e anche molto alla ribalta
Ecco la robotica vive in quello spazio
di intersezione tra meccanica fisica
elettronica e di informatica
è un equilibrio delicato tra hardware e
software
Ci vuole tempo
dedizione dietro un robot Ci sono
migliaia di ore di lavoro
migliaia di righe di codice
calcoli circuiti
ed anche se
spesso alla ribalta vediamo
realtà di Oltremare noi nel nostro
piccolo Cerchiamo di portare avanti i
nostri progetti tra molte difficoltà
come il budget o il tempo
Ma come nasce un robot
il robot nasce da un'idea da un progetto
pensato per operare all'interno di un
determinato ambiente
in un certo senso e l'ambiente che
disegna il robot
secondo un meccanismo del tutto simile
all'evoluzione naturale
se i robot non si adatta al suo ambiente
si estingue
E che cosa vuol dire che non si adatta
Beh se il robot per esempio deve
prendere degli oggetti e non ha le mani
non si adatta
Ma che dici Io non mi estinguo
Certo tu non ti estingui Ecco questo
robot per esempio si chiama l'abbiamo
chiamato uranus alle mani saluto
avrannos
non mi dà retta
ok
è così i robot sono così questo è
titanus
alle mani ma altre peculiarità
[Musica]
Ecco io adesso le flessioni non non le
faccio quantomeno non su un palco non di
fronte al pubblico
e però qui veniamo al punto è meglio
l'uomo o il robot
Esiste il pericolo che I robot un giorno
ci sostituiscano
la risposta
è la risposta terribile è sì
i robot su tante cose sono meglio di noi
ma è in un certo senso è una fortuna
questo fa sì che l'uomo non debba quasi
più essere
sottoposto a mansioni eccessivamente
gravose oppure operare all'interno
di ambienti pericolosi
pensate
nella nostra giornata noi
a volte deleghiamo delle scelte A delle
intelligenze artificiali
questo perché a volte
l'intelligenza artificiale è meglio
della stupidità naturale e di stupidità
naturale purtroppo ultimamente ne
vediamo in giro parecchia
i robot possono essere
autonomi controllati semici controllati
e questo ci dà lo spazio per tutta una
serie di applicazioni pensate per
esempio allo sminamento mediante robot a
distanza poi uno chiaro che si chiede
perché le mine debbano essere lì
Ma questo riguarda più la stupidità
naturale che l'intelligenza artificiale
importante è toglierle oppure pensate
alle operazioni in
chirurgia robotica
e quindi
c'è una buona notizia
nel senso che il meccanismo non si
autosostiene Cioè l'uomo è necessario
ad oggi i robot non possono esistere
senza l'uomo
[Musica]
[Applauso]
quindi i robot
sono utili
a volte insostituibili
sono studio lavoro svago
e quando funzionano Anche divertimento
ma c'è una cosa che non dobbiamo
dimenticare
nel corso della nostra evoluzione ciò
che ci ha contraddistinto
è stato l'uso che abbiamo fatto del
nostro intelletto quindi robot con un
robot intelligenza artificiale o no
ciò che l'essere umano deve fare e non
smettere mai di studiare e di imparare
ed a proposito di questo a proposito
dell'imparare O dell'esperire potrei
parlarvi per ore di questo ma immagino
che vogliate andare a casa
vi lascio con una citazione
del grande Leonardo da Vinci
o questi non sanno che le mie cose non
sono più da esser tratte
dall'esperienza che dall'altro di parole
Grazie a tutti
[Applauso]
[Musica]